My family name is Frankenstein.
I am a Genevese and my family is one of the most important in that country.
When I was about fifteen years old, there was a bad storm.
Lightning struck a tree near our house.
It completely destroyed the tree.
Until this time, I had not studied electricity.
But now, I lost interest in everything else.
My new interest was to lead to my own destruction.
From this time, science, especially chemistry and electricity, was my main interest.
I read widely, attended the lectures, and got to know many of the teachers.
A subject I studied in great detail was the human body.
I wanted to know what caused life and what caused death.
Then finally, I decided to use my knowledge.
I set about creating a human being.
It was one o'clock in the morning when I, at last, succeeded in creating life.
As I looked at the lifeless human being, I saw one eye slowly open,...
...then he began to breathe and move his arms.
At first, I thought he would be a fine - looking man.
I soon realized that there was nothing beautiful about him.
I ran out of the room, disgusted by the creature I had created.